listen up jorgey the secret key can be
traced to these
[Music]
coordinates but that's the White House I
know hold on hold on your fingers are
zooming in like way more than the screen
is is there like a responsiveness issue
don't you see the importance of this
just read this part of the article I
mean again it's just like you're
randomly moving your finger why aren't
you listening I'll just text Joey what
and I'll send him a selfie okay clearly
that's just the film camera they didn't
even bother trying to make it look like
an iPhone picture poor hey what's going
on the screen is just green now actually
that makes sense don't worry I'm hacking
the computer
chip stop